JESSE COLIN SOCIALIST
BERNIE SANDERS UNDER FIRE OVER
HIS LOVE AFFAIR WITH FIDEL
>> WHAT I SAID IS WHAT
BARACK OBAMA SAID IN TERMS OF
CUBA, THAT CUBA MADE PROGRESS ON
EDUCATION.
YES --
[BOOS]
REALLY?
WHETHER IT’S THE CHINESE OR WHEN
CUBA DOES SOMETHING GOOD, YOU
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO TRADE LOVE
LETTERS WITH THEM.
>> Jesse: THAT’S THE START OF
BERNIE’S PROBLEMS.
THE DEMOCRATIC FRONT RUNNER
GETTING HIT FROM ALL SIDES.
>> IMAGINE SPENDING THE BETTER
PART OF 2020 WITH BERNIE SANDERS
VERSUS DONALD TRUMP.
>> SOMEONE IN CHARGE OF THIS
TICKET HAS TO PUT FORWARD
$60 TRILLION IN SPENDING, THREE
TIMES OF THE AMERICAN ECONOMY?
I DO NOT THINK WE DO.
>> TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT WITH BERNIE.
BERNIE HAS NOT PASSED MUCH OF
EVERYTHING.
>> I DID THE WORK AND BERNIE’S
TRAIN CRASHED
TRASH ME FOR IT.
>> I’M HEARING MY NAME QUITE A
BIT TONIGHT.
>> Jesse: HE GOT THE FRONT
RUNNER TREATMENT LAST NIGHT.
I DO NOT THINK THE ATTACKS ARE
SHARP ENOUGH AND BLEEDING MOUTH,
AND HE SURVIVES.
>> Dana: WHY DID THEY WAIT
UNTIL NOW?
BERNIE SANDERS HAD THESE
POSITIONS FOR SO LONG AND IS
WEIGHTED TO AMASS THESE
DELEGATES AND A FOOTHOLD IN THE
RACE AND BASICALLY SAYING, I
KNOW ALL OF YOU ARE ATTACK ME 33
TIMES COMPARED TO BLOOMBERG’S 17
IN THIS DEBATE BECAUSE I HAVE
THE LEG UP, BUT ALL THOSE
ATTACKS THAT ARE COMING FROM
WITHIN HIS OWN PARTY ARE NOT
GOING TO LOOK VERY GOOD IN
GENERAL ELECTION ADS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TEAM WILL RUN
AGAINST BERNIE SANDERS.
THE FACT THAT BERNIE ISN’T GOING
TO CHANGE HIS MIND THAT MAYBE
THAT WORKS WITH BERNIE.
I WILL SAY THIS, HIS TEAM HAS A
MUCH BETTER CAMPAIGN THAN THE
HILLARY CLINTON TEAM.
THEY ARE ORGANIZED, THEY ARE
QUICK, THEY ARE KIND OF FUNNY,
THEY ARE EVERYWHERE.
DID YOU SEE WHAT THEY ARE DOING
IN MINNESOTA GOING RIGHT INTO
KLOBUCHAR’S BACKYARD WITH A BAND
I DIDN’T RECOGNIZE, THE NIGHT
SHIFTS OR SOMETHING?
I’M GOING TO FIND THE BAND FOR
YOU.
THEY ARE SUPER AGGRESSIVE AND
THEY ARE SMART AND THESE THINGS
WILL LOOK GOOD IN A GENERAL
ELECTION AD BUT I DO NOT THINK
IT HURT SOME OF THE PRIMARIES.
JESSE COLIN GREG, EXCLUDE ME WHY
BERNIE FEELS A NEED TO SAY GOOD
THINGS ABOUT BAD PEOPLE?
>> Greg: HE WAS KIND OF HAVE A
ON CUBA.
CUBA DIDN’T MAKE IMPROVEMENTS IN
EDUCATION, THEY MADE
IMPROVEMENTS IN REEDUCATION.
GOT A LITTLE IMPROVED.
WHEN HE WAS ASKED HOW THE
PAPER’S STUFF, HE SAID TO HIM
HOW MUCH TIME DO YOU HAVE?
BUT THAT IS SCARY STUFF FOR THE
DEMS, DESPITE ALL OF THAT, HE
STILL THE BEST SPEAKER.
HE KNOWS HOW TO SHUT PEOPLE UP.
HE GETS UP THERE, HE’S TALKING,
HE GIVES GOING IN AND GOING IN.
MEANWHILE YOU HAVE BUTTIGIEG
DOING THE UNDER TALK.
HERE I AM OVER HERE, YOU HAVE
MOLECULES...
I WILL BE HERE AND I’M RELAXED
AND CONFIDENT.
I SEE THAT AND I THINK BERNIE IS
REALLY GOOD.
HE MIGHT BE THE MOST ORBITAL
AGAINST TRUMP ON THE DEBATE
STAGE.
>> Jesse: MAYBE.
I THINK TRUMP WHICH YOU WILL UP
LIVE.
BERNIE SANDERS ONE ON ONE, HE’S
NOT HAD TO DEFEND THESE CRAZY
POSITIONS ONE ON ONE.
>> Juan: I THINK THAT’S WHAT
HE’S DOING NOW.
>> Jesse: THERE IS A FIELD OF
SEVEN OR ECHO.
>> Juan: REMEMBER, THERE’S A
LINE OF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHO’S
THE REAL SOCIALIST, THE GUY
GIVING MONEY TO THE RICH?
IT WOULD BE REALLY STRONG, I
DON’T THINK THAT’S A PROBLEM.
I THINK THE PROBLEM IS, AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
DISCUSSED IF YOU’VE WATCHED ON
"THE FIVE."
LEFT-WING PEOPLE IN GENERAL ARE
TWO PEOPLE TO OPENLY FOLKS LIKE
CASTRO, THE LIBERATION MOVEMENTS
IN LATIN AMERICA,
NORTHERN IRELAND, THEY ARE GOING
TO SAY SOMEHOW, THIS IS THE
RESISTANCE.
WE UNDERSTAND YOU’RE UP AGAINST
THE MAN, THE BIG CORPORATE
INTERESTS, AMERICAN MILITARY
POWER.
THE PROBLEM IS THESE MOVEMENTS
TURN OUT TO BE NOT GOOD PEOPLE
AND I CAN TELL YOU FROM MY
FAMILY HISTORY, PEOPLE WHO
OPPRESS AND ARE DISCRIMINATORY.
THE SANDINISTAS, HOW DID WE GET
INVOLVED WITH THEM?
THE OTHER DAY WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE WOMAN IN, WHAT ASIAN
COUNTRY, WAS A
IT BMR
GOING AFTER THE DISSIDENTS INHER
>> Dana: ON SANS
>> Juan: I DO NOT THINK IT
MOVES THE NEEDLE ON BERNIE’S
SUPPORTERS.
IF YOU’RE A GUY AND YOU ARE IN
PENNSYLVANIA, YOU SAY I CANNOT
PAY MY HEALTH CARE PREMIUM IN MY
COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: YOU DON’T CARE WHAT
HE SAYS ABOUT CASTRO.
>> Juan: IF YOU ARE GOING TO
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM FOR ME, YOU
ARE MY GUY, BERNIE.
>> Dana: THE CUBA HEALTH CARE
UTOPIA HAS BEEN A STAPLE OF THE
LAST SINCE THE CUBAN REVOLUTION,
SOMETHING THEY’VE PRAISE,
INDUCTION DATED IN COLLEGE
CLASSROOMS FOR DECADES.
THIS IS NOTHING NEW.
WHERE IT’S GOING TO HURT BERNIE
IN A GENERAL ELECTION, HE’S
GOING TO RAISE TAXES ON
EVERYTHING A PERSON IN AMERICA
WHICH HE ADMITS, GOING TO TAKE
AWAY YOUR HEALTH INSURANCE FOR
THE GREEN YOUR DEAL IS GOING TO
COST THE AVERAGE FAMILY $75,000
JUST FOR THE FIRST YEAR, WHICH
IS DOUBLE THE AVERAGE OF WHAT
THE AMERICAN FAMILY MAKES IN THE
YEAR, AND THE OTHER THING IS IF
BERNIE SANDERS WERE TO SOMEHOW
WIN THE WHITE HOUSE, WHICH I DO
NOT THINK YOU SHOULD COUNT THEM
OUT AT THIS POINT BECAUSE WE
DON’T KNOW, THE SQUAD IS GOING
TO BE RUNNING EVERYTHING.
AOC WILL BE IN CHARGE OF
SOMETHING, HER STAFFERS WILL BE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, RASHIDA
TLAIB WILL COME WITH HER.
ILHAN OMAR?
SAME THING FOR IT SHALL COME IN
AND BE APPOINTED TO SOMETHING.
>> Jesse: ALONG WITH HER
BROTHER.
>> Katie: THIS IS AN ENTIRE
RESTRUCTURING OF AMERICA.
>> Greg: YOU CONVINCED ME IT
WOULD BE TERRIBLE FOR THE